[Music]  the batman superman dynamic works  because they're archetypes some writers  have treated them adversarially some of  them treated them as as best friends  hanging out we're going to meet  somewhere in the middle  the first arc of batman superman world's  finest introduces the devil nezha who is  this ancient villain who has been  imprisoned for centuries and centuries  who's come back  to fight the heroes of today the book is  batman superman world's finest but  really it's  superman batman and robin world's finest  having him in the series gives me a  window to do a little bit more sort of  acrobatic adventuring dan blew my mind  with the injection of red kryptonite  into superman's heart he blew my mind  with the shots of matalo who was  absolutely appropriately frightening the  book looks as fresh and present and  contemporary as anything else we're  publishing  [Music]  you